cnn have you seen this channel they've
got this stelter guy the potato man and
he's got now his sidekick oliver darcy
who i think sort of used to be a
conservative and then he went the other
way which these people like what's the
deal what's the deal with that uh well
they had a guest on who just made even
less sense than what you'd usually find
on cnn but that's that's the goal right
the goal of this kind of coverage is to
freak people out to cause them to live
in fear ironically a lot of the
fear-mongering is about the things that
are not actually mortal threats and then
there's ignoring the things that are
mortal threats you know covet isn't real
and climate change isn't real i would
argue that to me anyway those things are
a little bit scarier or have been
scarier at various points in the past
couple of years and instead it's about
the immigrant hordes and the senile
president and critical race theory
brainwashing your kids and and things
that are you know
if if not
just exaggerated invented out of whole
cloth
oh right that's right critical race
theory being taught in school you all
know this is happening all over the
place it's exactly why glenn younkin won
in virginia yes they try to get you on
some definition of critical race theory
that it's not exactly what's taught but
we are we know they're dividing classes
by race they're making it easier for
certain students based on skin color or
gender or whatever to get into certain
clubs or to play different sports all
you know all of the stuff so she's
saying okay it's just invented out of
whole cloth it's either exaggerated or
invented out of whole cloth also biden's
cognitive decline it's like uh that is a
problem that is a problem you know
there's this putin guy and he's not this
really great guy he may want to do some
bad stuff in the world and putin he may
want to invade ukraine it seems like
it's going to happen now i don't know
what we're supposed to do i don't
personally i don't think we should do
anything probably like it just kind of
sucks but i don't think we have the
wherewithal as a country to really do
anything at the moment but do you think
that putin is afraid of joe biden who
obviously has severe cognitive decline
and to link this to our previous story
as well it's like that's one of the
things we don't talk about but suddenly
when one of the good liberals either jon
stewart or bill maher or somebody will
talk about biden's cognitive decline
publicly well then suddenly everyone
will be talking about it and all of us
crazy right-wing conservatives they'll
go oh well you guys were still racists
and conspiracy theorists and everything
else but you know now we're going to
just say the thing that you've been
saying for
uh two years so what's interesting about
this is it shows it it's just one of
those things where
it shows you the layer being peeled off
these people they lie about all of these
things right they lie about critical
race theory in school they lie about
biden's cognitive decline you know all
the stuff about you know brett
kavanaugh's a serial rapist the
covington kids are all racist donald
trump very fine people like you know all
they lie about absolutely everything but
when something pops up
that is somewhat true like critical race
theory in schools and some of this other
stuff woke-ism all of the nonsense
that's exaggerated or invented out of
whole cloth like you see the difference
there when we lie it's we're lying for
the greater good or something like that
and that's a little bit different